What do I think about methylene blue? Well, methylene blue is great. So, I think methylene blue has been shown with some people to be super beneficial for cancer. It's very anti-inflammatory.
It's, I think it shines even more with brain inflammation.
But to help ward off dementia to decrease inflammation in the brain, you know, given other issues.
So, even if I have, let's say, a lymphoma and, you know, it's, you know, in my abdominal cavity, can methylene blue help? It can.
So, methylene blue is one of those like fendizole and I've hermectin. Some people that doesn't work with help their cancer at all.
And just because there's tons of testimonials for that, we have tons of testimonials for the right. We have tons of testimonials for, you know, mushrooms.
Mushrooms, we have tons of testimonials for everything. It just means it doesn't mean it's going to work the same for everyone.
So, we just have to keep that in balance. But, I mean, there really is no harm to foul and tried methylene blue versus fendizole, which can have side effects and can affect your liver, can affect your kidneys.
And like somebody else said, it's causing issues with, you know, their possible cold source and some weird side effects.
And I've hermectin is a drug. And so, somebody asked a question last week, should I, can I take I've hermectin? You know, even if I'm in, my cancer is stable and I just want to stay healthy.
I would not be something I would do. It's a drug still.
Methylene blue isn't really a drug. So, methylene blue is not going to have, there's like no known side effects for methylene blue.
So, I would say, if you take it within the normal dose, the standard dose, you're going to be just fine. I don't see any problem with taking it.
I've seen videos of people going absolute gonzo on methylene blue because, oh, if this is good for you, then 10 times more must be even better for you.
Well, that's your barricade, misnomer on everything. So, we got to keep a balance of that. So, I don't have any problem with methylene blue.